we left off where you told the story of
how you were
making me stacking millions of dollars
in the stock market
and you had an ecstasy
empire in arizona tempe arizona
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] was going on you
finally got busted went to jail
or prison and i think we left off
with the story of the roaches and
you met a guy named two tonys so we left
off when you were in prison i know we
missed a lot of really interesting
stories
and from inside prison the people you
met and then from when you actually got
out and what happened after you got out
so where where can we start well if we
didn't do the xena
transgender story that would be the
best one to start with okay so
xena was a six and a half foot
charismatic
transgender prisoner looked
longer you know um
kind of like skinny but like bum coming
out you know
going around like a woman on the yard
and i made friends with xena
and what i didn't know when i made
friends xena was
that zene had something suffered
something completely horrific
when she first came in i'll say she
because that's the trans
they find it disrespectful to say he so
xena came in
two decades before me and she clicked up
with the ap
to urine brotherhood she was
working out she was big and they
had her collecting debts now
with these gangs it's blood then blood
out they use people up and they
brutalize them
and in xena's case i asked her what
happened
she said the first time was a gang rape
they came they beat me until i was
unconscious
raped me while i was unconscious and
shoved things inside my body
i said how do you know
that they were raping you if you were
unconscious
she said when i went the toilet after i
could tell by what came out
oh i said what did they stick inside
your body
a broomstick
so what did you do after being raped she
said
she got moved to another yard but the
same thing happened they beat her up
used her as a prostitute a punk
more more gang rapings and
and she sounds like a big person right
yeah she was six and a half foot
i've seen him big guys come in prison
full of bravado and the gangs get on
them like a pack of wolves
there's nothing they could do when
someone's outnumbered it's not like in
the movies where rambo just kicks ass
and everyone goes down yeah the gangs
they run the place they decide who lives
and dies
so xena said she sat in the cell waiting
for the scars to go away
she got moved but the same thing
happened
and we were writing a blog to raise
awareness of prison rape
so i said you know does this happen to
young people
who come in and she said yeah mostly
young people what can happen to anyone
big bad dudes skinny even the ugliest
people in the world
people who come to prison who aren't
street smart and don't understand the
mentality of ghetto life
they get preyed on the most i said well
how did you stop it
she said that she started fighting back
she won the fight and she told him she
didn't occur
if she lived or died and that's how she
stopped it
but that's understatement
xena was studying anatomy at the time
she came with an idea
and the next two times the gang came to
rape zena
the first member of the gang to put his
hand on xena
xena plucked his eyeball out so it was
dangling from the optic nerve
so xena did that on two separate
occasions
and was classified as extremely
dangerous because
when i heard this i thought that's not
even possible but when i got out i
joined a dojo and they teach us in
karate it's called bird beak strike
we just pull someone's eyeball out like
that so when the eyeball comes out it's
dangling from the optic nerve
it doesn't just go back in the eye and
behave normally
the fluid cushioning the brain can leak
through it and you can die
your eye might end up looking the wrong
way you could be blinded so after doing
that twice
the gang left cena alone but they moved
on to some of the other more vulnerable
prisoners
saw zina's friends actually one was gang
raped
and they held him down and they took a
light bulb and shoved it in his backside
and made bets on who could smash it
first
and that prisoner committed suicide
afterwards
another one was gang raped they held him
down
cut his head off with a shovel and when
the shovel was finally off
they picked their head up and they
positioned it in an area of the prison
where the rival gangs would see it
to make the point that they were the
most violent and ruthless out of all the
gangs and that was the irian brotherhood
prison gang
now another thing xena told me was you
know
people think you know how can this
happen all this man on man rape
um you know the guards would protect the
prisoners the
culprits would be brought to justice
well people who think that are in a
dream world
this is an extremely violent
predatory society like a warrior society
where you got two guards watching
hundreds of prisoners
so cena said you know
you can't get anyone prosecuted the
victim is labeled a rat
a punk and considered less than human
you can't go to the guard because then
you're a snitch for snitches it's kos
kill on sight by everybody
or the guards will put you in a dungeon
for months or years and say it's for
your own protection
you can do absolutely nothing other than
kill the perpetrators
and i asked all did you think about
killing them and she said yeah
i thought about killing them i thought
about killing myself
and i still do and then she started
crying and she couldn't answer any more
questions
now xena also did something to herself
and the truck that i met a trans
prisoner who'd fully done this
thing to to herself and
xena copied this she had a mosby's
medical dictionary she had no
painkillers whatsoever
she wakes up one morning just drinks a
cup of coffee
gets a felt-tip pen a marker and draws
some lines on her scrotum
picks up a razor blade slashes her
scrotum open
the testicles are on branches called the
vas deferens
so she falls the scrotum open she's got
the blade
on the spermatic cord and grizzle that's
holding this
testicle to the vas deferens and she
chops through it
and manages to get one testicle off
now the testicle must have known what
was coming
because it retracted insider
so she's now got her hands in her guts
looking for this other testicle she says
she could feel squishy things like
organs and stuff
and she's rummaging around and uh and
as [ __ ] as she's rummaging around she's
starting now to feel
the red-hot pain of cutting one ball off
but she's thinking you know this is a
one-shot deal i gotta do it
so she's scrambling around in her guts
looking for it and where she's got it
tied off
to stop the blood squirting out comes
undone
so now the blood starts squirting across
the cell
and she's got the red hot pain kicking
in and she's going faint and she's
scrambling around in the guts looking
for the other
nut and it's it's hiding further and
further in there
and um in the end
she's she's bleeding to death she's
losing consciousness
and somebody sees her and they managed
to get a helicopter
to the prison just in time to get into
hospital to save her life
now she was put on suicide watch for
over a year
and when she got off suicide watch she
cut the other one off
so what the trans prisoners do is
they cut the testicles off to stop the
testosterone and they get estrogen
smuggled in
they believe they are women trapped in
men's bodies
and yeah they feel more at peace
by doing that by reversing the flow of
the chemicals
i